Fresh Prince asking
I hear storytelling a lot nowadays and
we talked about this at the top what's
one way I can do that on social media on
Instagram as an example I think it's a
great question Fresh Prince and there's
a couple of things that I think on
social you know
instagrams Grey awesome channel go where
your audiences if that's the
demographics of your audience and they
like to be interested in your idea or
product then that's absolutely where you
go or Facebook or maybe more traditional
channels of Twitter but I think
definitely is fantastic so you could
embrace that channel the other thing I
think is really you know you have to
have compelling content so things like
Instagram great visual for visualization
pictures video and also I think on
social media as well the great thing
about social media is it's not all kind
of one shot it's a continuous
conversation it's it's a storytelling
and one of the most compelling ways to
tell your story and I guess it's the way
where you start with is what am i what
problem I sold them for my customer what
is what is the pain point that my
customers going through or every day
then I'm gonna you know alleviate what
what is the game they're gonna get from
it and if so if you kind of answer that
question you're really clear about what
what problem I sorted for my customer
what is the pain point and then you show
through stories you know especially with
pictures and physical isolation then I
think you're off you know to a winner
and then great thing with social you can
get other people involved and you can
kind of build a community where you are
one of the opinion leaders on the
conversation and you're one of the
participants in terms of shaping the
conversation and that's so powerful and
I I think yeah the first thing is again
you want to if you got the idea you know
what you want to do you know what pain
point it souls you've got a great idea
in terms of how to show your product and
you can you know show up through demos
pictures videos or less sort of stuff
then you get out there and do it because
you'll find other people out there
who'll be really willing to contribute
and they'll be you know degree
thing is you get loads of almost like
instant feedback market research
whatever you want to call it and it's
all free it's all freely just lap it up
and evolve your product according to the
advice you get in from from the folks
out in the community I think for any
kind of storytelling is understanding
first what are you staying for like
what's your mission what's your value
like for me believe I want to help
entrepreneurs everything that I create
whose's believes every video I make
every interview I do every picture that
I post and I think what you want to do
is create something that you want to go
and show your grandkids like you want to
create something that you're so proud of
that you want your grandkids to see and
every post that you're creating and so
within an Instagram structure it's a
crime typically has been you put your
best picture out there right he's like
you curate all of these pictures you
take a thousand pictures and like one of
them your best one is the one you're
gonna put up but the recent change with
stories has been super interesting and
now you have the ability to tell stories
along along your day just like snapchat
does it disappears in 24 hours and so
it's a chance to develop the more human
side of what's real about what your
routine looks like the behind-the-scenes
talking to customers and so it's a great
way I think that entrepreneurs can win
because that's how you beat bigger
players in your industry is the human
connection is the it's the why because
you care more about what you're doing
then some other big corporation might in
your space and so going all in on your
story is gonna be really important and
Instagram is a great way to do it so
these quick 10-second clips of what's
happening your day why you started this
thing and why it's also good as you
don't need to have a big budget Steven
talked about it being free people don't
expect like with YouTube there's still
some expectations of our video quality
and a lot of players are spending a lot
of money with production crews and
cameramen and lights and all that and
with an Instagram story or snapchat it's
expected to be real it's expected to be
a little more gritty because it's just
taken from your phone and so that's
really an awesome chance for you to
practice telling your story sharing what
is so important to you in your day to
day life and the chance for your
customers and your audience and your
followers to understand you better and
connect with what you're all about so I
would highly recommend that is a
practice even just for you to practice
because you know what's going away in 24
hours the thing only lives for 24 hours
those stories so developing the
communication skill to talk into an
audience is a really valuable exercise
to go through